he's a Hong Kong actor film director
producer stuntman and singer he's known
for performing his own stunts
he is a cultural icon he Jackie Chan and
here is top ten girls for success say
look why why don't we change everything
up is a Busan be myself just me check
you change that takes a lot of
confidence yeah I believe it also I
really thank you you know the producer
who see us he said okay do whatever you
like to do yeah change Nobu sleep comedy
when Bruce Lee King high
I click low when Bruce Lee after punch I
just wow just like normal human being
normal when I was young I'm fighting on
the street one by one oh my knock
somebody down to buy one that somebody
down three I'm run away so in the movie
do the same thing I just everything used
in the movie use my it's my real life
choose the good things do my own way
even though I try to get American market
they don't like my idea don't they don't
like this kind of humor and Marshall are
fighting I just insist you're gonna come
back to Hong Kong I go my own way risk
my life for doing the Jackie Chan style
I never give up even though I fell down
the US I never give up still I'm not
because I American market changed my own
style but after 15 years now the whole
Hollywood action everybody wanna learn
for me a test I to do the right things
so this way I always tell the people not
because one one things fall down you
just give up never give up never give up
one day you SEC in the old day when I
started action movies i I just make
audience laughing you know do all the
funny things you know College oh but I
just and kick the ball
really yeah but slowly slowly from the
audience from the audience from the
media I special from the fence they
write the letter
oh now I have a baby so say I cannot see
the movie because the dirty word because
the dirty action because this all those
years I change change change change
change without all the dirty things
still can make Audion laughing that's it
difficult it's the audience all offense
or the mediate teach me becoming a good
filmmaker when you see the famous people
why are so successful you don't know
what behind this story how tough they
are what they're when I like people
watch a key to move so good when
everybody sleep I still in the half club
in a mirror practicing practicing mmm
like this and wait which and 4 o'clock 6
o clock it up on a set then you
certainly do something very beautiful oh
yeah
go back train again ok there's a snake
head that's up sneak now that's the
snake tongue okay you cream all things
some other crease is done if I think I
cannot do it I already canceled it yeah
some really crazy things you I believe I
can do it I already do it like was like
jump jump over the building Joe crashed
by the hovercraft jump from the light 72
feet high with no net and this so many
things so many things even even today I
look at the old film look at myself
sometimes rias mine
I'm glad even I know I get hurt I broke
my angle I'm so happy I did it if today
I cannot do it anymore
yeah I'm so whatever you want to do
whatever you always tell the students
what
do do the when you young do it you might
get hurt
are you learning a piano you're learning
a martial art between between ten or
twenty ten years learn whatever you can
those here like me I just do ten years
later now forever
the things you learn or the the success
I have forever don't regret one day ah I
should do it right now
I should know it's too late do it when
you were young I think as a
producer-director we do have a
responsibility for your own society for
the family or for for the world so I
hope we can unite it together to make a
better movie for the world for the peace
for the for everything yeah not just
making money money you cannot live
forever the movie you can live forever
everybody know yes how do you feel when
people copy you know I'm not happy that
means I'm success okay yeah it also
pushes you right and also pushing it I
want a different like what I do in
accommodate they do comedy we're not
doing a action they doing action okay
how can I different okay I do dangerous
stuff
nobody copy me that means not one scrap
there everything okay check it you do
that then I just continue doing that
dangerous stunts every day when it on
the set I just do the best I can every
movie I I risk my life that you do the
things not for the the beginning is not
for the fans it for myself because I
have to do the best I can then lately
becoming my trademark
Wow Jackie Reese's life come boom boom
yeah when I'm making a movie after the
finish the movie is done
I ask myself can my movies showing my
children yes then I let my children to
see it then if I my children can see the
whole world children can see I didn't
have a good go to school when I was
young every day just fighting fighting
training and I am a very bad boy when I
was young really my parents in Australia
just by myself everyday what I see all
the tires against earth and raising car
fighting people beating people the area
what I see so I was very lucky I didn't
join the triad
I'd enjoy the Mafia to cut up I clear
yeah that's that we all have friends sit
on the table
okay everybody to have 300 us okay 300
then we can sell the drug the drug would
then we can get 900 back then then
everybody gives 300 then Jackie come on
then I look at them I was like 16
something because I promised my father
never came off we were try it never get
away anymore for with drugs never
getting over in the casino gambling I
said sorry am i I promised my father oh
come on
don't beat our 300 you can I so sorry
sorry because that promise is promise
then I never get involved these kind of
things the best story for me I think
when I was young
doing an undated Greg and fighting with
Bruce Lee and I was behind the camera ho
waiting waiting I just see booze then I
just you run after that then he pull
back satiny my eyes black because he's
just one stick right on my hair ah he
missed it but I just I do nothing I just
ah and I just fell no little dizzy but
it's okay I look at it boosts Lee Bruce
Lee doesn't do anything you look at
everybody and keep acting turn around
back unto the direct and say cut and he
just saw the two stick just turn around
oh my god he run to me and lift me up
I'm sorry I'm sorry
actually I'm not paying anymore because
no young guy on me very tough but
certainly I don't know why I just
pretend very painful oh oh
I just want boots a homie along as
always can I said oh I'm doing the whole
day every time you look at me like this
I said okay and I think that's the best
moment then somehow he'll run to me
what's your name as in my name Jackie
what style we're learning as a southern
style okay then talk to me
Jackie huh Jackie Jackie okay thank you
so much for watching I made this video
because M Kim asked me to so if there's
a famous entrepreneur that you I'm going
to profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Jackie
Chan's top 10 rules you love the most
leave it in the comments I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon